caught out in the canaries business
minister
paul scully instagramming from lanzarote
now dealing with his own government's
titan travel restrictions
the transport secretary also seemed out
of the loop having flown to spain for
his own holiday
grant shaps will now need to quarantine
when he gets home
questions for the government about
whether it could have acted sooner
especially given infections began rising
in the country
earlier in the week we got the data on
the spike on the friday we evaluated it
and changed the advice
on the saturday we couldn't have
responded more swiftly more decisively
and of course i take into account
the the challenges the airlines are
going through the passengers going to
spain but we've also
got to keep in our mind the big picture
here in scotland nicolas sturgeon only
took spain off the quarantine list on
monday
not just in relation to spain but
generally these situations are not cast
in stone
six days later that warning has been
borne out the first minister's political
opponents
accusing her of ignoring the warning
signs coming from spain
travel firms are also angry questioning
why this move couldn't have come
24 hours earlier before the weekend
getaway
others worry that those forced to
self-isolate will be left with no income
as they won't be entitled to statutory
sick pay
under the current government rules you
can get the 95 pounds per week payment
if you are self-isolating because you or
someone you live with have symptoms
have come into contact with someone who
has the virus
or a high risk and shielding you won't
be eligible
if you're quarantining after returning
from abroad if you are somebody who
has come back from spain today and your
boss says you've got to be at work on
monday
there's not a great deal you can do if
they say
well if you don't come in i'm not going
to pay you and if you haven't been there
for two years
you've got very little protection
against being dismissed as well
the government says no one should be
penalized for acting within the rules
but labour isn't happy the government
just say oh we hope that employers
cooperate well
you know to be frank i hope that i'll
win the lottery on saturday doesn't mean
it's going to happen
we need clarity from government now as
to whether those who are astro
quarantined whether they'll get
financial support
if their employers refuse it then travel
businesses are also calling for support
battered by the lockdown this latest
move may shatter what little confidence
had returned to the sector
evidence if any was needed that this
virus will be disrupting lives
and livelihoods for some time yet rob
powell sky news in westminster